yes which one is this okay
let me first ask how told you 5 feet 10
inches or 11 if it's for a casting
director all right
are you not 510 and a half I 5 10 and a
quarter nobody believes you when you say
that okay but you're talking to me okay
I'm your friend 510 and a half could
work for me okay okay I've heard people
say I'm exactly 510 and I say what is
what do you mean by that if I want to
just be a pain in the ass what do you
mean well it came in exactly 510 right
well if you look at if you look at a
tape measure okay okay and you go to
like 510 right the the mark that
indicates 510 uh-huh has a thickness
okay so then you say this wait a minute
so you're saying that yeah what where do
you fall in the thickness of the mark
correct if that determines your exact
whatever measurement I what I'm saying
is that if you're measuring something
you can never know the answer exactly
it will only be an approximation that
you just agree to and move on I disagree
okay okay because I think about what you
said were true we couldn't have that
atomic clock you told me about oh well
do you remember stuff remember things
okay so let me tell you out the atomic
clock okay when did I tell you about the
atomic clock at about how the fact that
because measurement of time was not at
one point precise right okay okay
and that basically you couldn't have you
couldn't have this you wouldn't have the
same time one place as you would the
other because you didn't have well the
measurement of time measurement of time
wittingly so we went to an atomic time
right rather than earth reverse rotation
by the way and the
thing to was that the Earth's rotation
is not the same we didn't know that and
you can't know that if earth is your
measure so you all slowed the precision
measurement to an atom and the atom has
very high dependability in its frequency
that's vibrating you get how many times
it vibrates per second is the cesium
atom you do that you get that now you
look back at earth it oh my god
earth is slowing down right you could
not have known that without that know if
earth was your man what is Earth or the
means of measuring you would never know
that the correct as the mean itself is
actually slowing down correct okay so
all I'm saying is when you make a
measurement you can never know anything
precisely you can only know it to some
point where you agree so here's the best
example okay it's related to how tall
you are all right the best example I
asked you how long is the way I'm I'm
six hands tall that would only be that's
four inches oh I don't know I thought I
was using the one where horses but go
ahead write the hand okay so you don't
say how many feet so I mean hoofs oh
sorry
so the coastline of England all right
okay how long is it how would you go
about finding that out well I would take
you would have to measure the actual
squiggly luckily I get out a map that's
the a post get a nice big map right and
you get a squiggly line okay put a ruler
up against because it's squiggly so what
are you get like a string okay you take
the string and you do that
all right you coming at it and then you
when you're done you go out and you hold
it up against the sky oh it's six at
eight hundred miles long okay I don't
know the exact number so there it is but
wait a minute
if I had a bigger map it would show more
squiggles wouldn't it okay so with a
bigger map I want if I do this exercise
again my string is doing more as it goes
around now I got more string out of
better measurement it's well so it's not
just that it's a bigger map but of
course the scale is bigger but my string
did more right because I got more detail
okay
which length of the coastline of England
are you going to use the one from the
small map is one of the bigger man
probably the one of the Big Mac is made
more precise for you right are you done
no let's make it even bigger in fact
let's make a map the size of England
okay and now gonna have to do that
because England's there so now you just
go around with a string wait a minute
guys do that wait there's a boulder
there what side of the boulder you were
gonna go around wait a minute the tide
is coming in and out the coastline is
the boundary between land and water but
the water is not constant where are you
going to draw that when then you get
down to the to the to the to the sand
which same green are you gonna go around
what I'm telling you is making me not
believe in math a lot of time you is
yeah you can measure their circumference
of Colorado okay because it's got square
sides but when you guys squiggly lines
that measurement is an agreed upon point
where you're gonna say I give up let's
just call it this all right that's my
point that's the point right and and you
can say do you know you do is that you
make measure at high tide or at low tide
right or an in-between tide all right
you have to pick you have to at some
point you just have to say we're done
here guys okay how much do you weigh
okay I've had it scaler all right I got
a scale just like a kitchen scale okay
and I turn it on and it measures you
know I put you do the tear and tear and
all that and it'll say let's say three
three ounces okay is three and a quarter
ounces it doesn't register that it'll
only register again when it hits floor
ounces true wait so it can't measure
this scale cannot measure between three
and four ounces right now let's get
another skill that goes through tenth
seven ounce okay
so now you get three point four two
ounces 3.4 ounces okay what's the next
three point five so poaches in between
those okay can't measure that so now I
got a scale there does now you got it
scaled it goes to two decimal place and
you can take that all the way
right wait am it is ugly exactly because
now you have made scales and weight
summer into fractals because I'm late
yes you can just kiss come we can keep
going all the way down but you never get
you're never ever because we'll always
be societies so the line that you're
doing the measurement with it will
always have a thickness so you can
measure things to some approximation
that we all conversationally agree with
but you will never out care what it is
okay you can count precisely you're
exactly two of us here on this set okay
right there's not two and a half that we
can count that are we counting the
voices in my head
you have 3/4 of a voice I got 1/4 we
have to sleep so so you can count things
per second you cannot measure with
unlimited precision interesting yes that
is that but see no okay yeah now here's
what happen right just this past year
all right the kilogram something I know
nothing about because I'm American that
mark American non drug dealer kilos in
the international system of measures
that keeps track of the length of the
second and the lake the duration of a
second the length of a meter the and the
mass and a kilogram that the last thing
based on an artifact in that facility
was a kilogram was the kilogram yes
everything else is based on measurements
of on highly precise things that you can
duplicate in laboratories this was an
artifact sitting there that's a kilogram
by definition right okay right they said
we got it we can't do this anymore you
know why because they made copies of it
put them around the world and every now
and then they bring them back and none
of them are equal anymore
some are losing atoms there so they said
we need we got to fix this yeah so that
little thing that you see that wouldn't
use when it says it yeah okay
that little cylindrical a little candle
on the tablets when they're doing the
thing all right right correct
so you're saying that that no longer is
the proper measurement of a kilogram as
of the middle of 2019 that's correct
no longer because here's what they did
we have ways of making precise crystals
of silk
oh so precise that you can count the
atoms in the lattice that's pretty cool
so what they did was they took the
kilogram that's dill they this dope they
took the kilogram right and then they
made a silicon sphere pure silicon and
they made them equal each other okay
once you do that you throw away the
kilogram right and now I know exactly
how many silicon atoms equals a kilogram
so now I have an atomic representation
of what the kilogram measurement is and
I can count the atoms so there is no
uncertainty in the mass of the kilogram
right now and and I can tell people
around the world you want a kilogram
assemble this many silicon atoms the or
they also do also that - go ahead it's
it's avocados number what do you
remember him that's was what Avogadro's
number remember it was 6.02 times 10 to
the 23rd it's how many particles make a
mole right all right once you set the
kilogram with the silicon atoms you set
them you set how many part how many
particles are in a mole we've set
avocados number and it's now to nine
decimal places that is we got this
that's pretty little done that's cool so
it's true for everything you measure on
the speedometer your weight the time the
temperature there's always some range
across the indicator where it could be
at the bottom the middle or the top make
a thinner one there's gonna be a bottom
middle the top you will be doing that
all the way down that makes sense that
is the world of measurement so here we
go people
what have we learned believe nothing no
just as important we say we're good
you're fine I'm good with that
you're not 5/8 you're not six feet I'm
good with it I'm gonna be five eight and
seven five ten anyway this has been a
Startalk info bit thanks Chuck ya know
what helping me through it by the way
bite eight bits no isn't it
but this mate depends on what you're
eating
[Music]